it usually has a little bit of a delay
but
and then we'll have chat from the
audience and i will
feed those in uh so let me
first start let's see if this will work
yeah
okay that is i am not one mount the cena
but uh let's see if i can get this to
work here
there we go hello everybody uh watching
out
hopefully on youtube and elsewhere uh i
am brian keating uh the fearful host of
the into the impossible podcast
and today i'm joined by none other than
a legend
uh in the world of theoretical physics
cosmology
uh even i want to pick his brains about
economics and other things that
you might not associate with a physicist
working at the institute for advanced
study but juan i want to thank you for
joining us today how are you doing
hello nice to see you it's good to see
you too so
uh what i had originally pinged you
about is your willingness to come on to
discuss
a topic that we've been reviewing in my
research group
of cosmologists here at the university
of california san diego
well we like to do things outside of our
comfort zone and one of those things is
to do
uh research into the very deep and
provocative aspects
of theoretical particle physics and
uh and and also to investigate perhaps
the deeper philosophical implications of
the work that we do
and not only just you know turn screws
there's nothing wrong with turning
screws but
but uh certainly it's fun to get out of
our comfort zone and so we've been
reviewing your papers on
on wormholes and uh and even went to
your back catalog
as they might say and went into the
original papers on the subject and
we came up with a lot of questions but
uh hopefully uh hopefully we'll
answer some of those and some from the
audience who's listening
as well so the paper
in question is uh is entitled
humanly traversable wormholes and i
wonder
if uh we could start off um by talking
about the inspiration for that paper
uh and its predecessor paper which was
traversable wormholes not speaking
specifically about
uh humanly traversable yet but in 2018
you and your colleague alexi and fidor
popov wrote a paper called traversable
wormholes
i want to ask what was the impetus uh
for you to investigate something so
potentially fantastical as a wormhole
um well the
this came out of thinking about black
holes and
the black hole interior and entanglement
so there is uh
of course wormholes are fascinating to
think about regardless and
that's also why we're thinking about
this but
one pulse seem like they're very exotic
however
something like a wormhole is already
present in the simplest
solution of general relativity so if you
take the
general activity with the vacuum
solution and spherically symmetric
we assume spherical symmetry there is
some solution which schwarzschild wrote
which sometimes we call it the black
hole solution or the structural solution
and that solution has the peculiarity
that it has two exteriors connected by a
single interior
and this was a funny feature that
einstein and rosen noticed in the
30s and and yeah
it's been well known for a long time
and so this solution has the geometry of
a wormhole at the spatial instance so at
an instant of time in time
you have a three-dimensional space
hour three that i imagine you we had the
solution we would have
our three-dimensional space is connected
through a wormhole to a second copy of
another three-dimensional space
it has the funny feature that the
wormhole is not traversable so
if you try to go from one side to the
other you find that the solution is time
dependent
and this geometric connection closes off
and
there is a part of space that shrinks
you have a kind of big crunch
in the in this wormhole it shrinks
it's very similar to what would happen
if you took a piece of dough and you
stretched it a lot
it becomes very thin and that's what
happens to this geometry
uh and the resulting very thin space is
what we normally call the black hole
singularity
so if you try to traverse it you just
end the
singularity you die so not fine that's
to be avoided yes
yeah so that that's uh that's present
already in that solution it's
not traversable and i should emphasize
that if you had an actual black hole
that is produced in
through astrophysical processes you
don't get this full solution you only
get
a portion of this solution because usual
black
holes are not the solution of the vacuum
instant equations but the solutions with
matter
and those black holes those black holes
would have a geometry similar to the one
we discussed after a certain point
and then you encounter the matter of the
star that produced the black hole and
space somehow ends there and it doesn't
have a second side
um but it's a very closely related
geometry
um certainly allowed by instance
equations
simple solutions um
okay so that that's one geometry that's
one
part of the story another part of the
story comes from a different line of
reasoning which is
uh thinking about hawking radiation so
black holes have
this funny feature of emitting
some radiation so even though they are
solutions in the vacuum
they look like thermal objects they emit
radiations as if there were objects at
some temperature and
this radiation is very small for
astrophysical black holes but could be
larger for
smaller sized black holes so it's larger
the temperature of the radiation is
the smaller the black hole is you can
you can even run into the paradoxical
situation of having a white black hole
because uh if the black hole has the
size of the order of uh
a micronurse but smaller than micron the
the size of the wavelength of
light you you would see it white
so um
and so that's a feature of black holes
it involves quantum mechanical aspects
and by thinking about these quantum
mechanical aspects and some other
features of black holes people came up
with this uh
conjecture that i would i like to
sometimes call it the central dogma of
quantum black holes
it's like you know like there is a
central dogma in biology there is
central dogma of quantum aspects of
black holes
which is that if you look at the black
hole from outside
you can think of it as an ordinary
quantum system as an ordinary system
it obeys the loss of thermodynamics it
obeys the loss of quantum mechanics
and so on um and it does so in a rather
non-trivial way with an intricate
way in which the loss of
physics conspired to give a picture
where this would be consistent
and if you apply if you have this
solution like the one we discussed with
uh
of charshall um that contains uh
there is a closely related solution
where these two two space times that
look completely disconnected are
actually part of the same
space time so you have a solution which
looks like two black holes that are
separated in space
but are connected through um
are connected through the interior so
they share a single interior
and the idea is that
if you apply this sort of central dogma
separately to which black holes which
black hole can be replaced by quantum
system
and then the peculiarity that produces
the connection is
or the idea is that the connection will
arise if
uh these two quantum systems are
entangled with each other so they have
epr or ancient velociros entanglement
and um yeah so that's a
that's an idea for what it's an
interpretation if you wish of the
russian solution in light of uh of this
this results of hawking and others about
quantum aspects black holes
and again there the the fact that it is
not traversable is good
because you cannot send information
using entanglement
so it's a consistency i mean it's
consistent with this
interpretation um
now and people well we studied this
relationship a lot to try to learn about
black hole interiors
basically that's how how we should think
about black hole interiors
and there are weird features about black
hole interior such as this one the two
two separate black holes can share the
same interior for example
and so it's like an exotic system that
we would like to study to understand
better than black hole interiors
um now
um okay now the the next development in
this
direction uh came from an observation
paper by gao jefferies and wall um
and they realized that if you
introduce some interaction between these
two black holes in the ambient space
you could get the signal to go through
this wormhole and send the signal is
closely related to quantum teleportation
so if you
have two quantum systems that are
entangled
then by doing certain measurements and
sending qubits on one of them
and sending classical information to the
other you could
you could send a qubit you could
teleport the qubit and in
in this gravity picture the the qubit is
really going through the wormhole so
you create um you do a certain operation
using the infer so
roughly speaking what you do is you
measure the caulking radiation on one
black hole
and yeah sorry i should start from the
beginning
you have the two entangled black holes
you send the qubit that you want to send
into one of the black holes
then you do you measure the hawking
radiation of that black hole you send
information to the other
and by knowing that information the the
person in the other black hole can send
the negative energy pulse is something
that
normally could not be done into a normal
black hole but if you
roughly speaking the hawking radiation
is random but
if it is entangled with another one and
you measure the other one you know what
is going to happen it's like having
inside information it's like in the
stock market market it looks like a
black hole if you don't know nothing but
if you
have a friend inside the company and
tells you something then
i would never do that i would never
we'll cover economic trickery when we
get to uh the higgs mechanism but
yeah but this is um this is similar in
the sense that you can
you can lower the energy of the black
hole go you send in some negative energy
pulse and then you can
get out of the from the interior this uh
cubit that you sent on the other side so
it's a
an interesting picture for what's
happening with quantum teleportation and
listing this setup
and yeah so the these papers that you
mentioned were
sort of developing this idea a little
more
just uh looking for situations where
very naturally you would have this
interaction between these two black
holes
that it would happen in uh for ordinary
four-dimensional
black holes and so on and uh
so the the crucial aspect
in both well in all the solutions is to
have two black holes that are relatively
close to each other
so that there is some interaction
between them
and so that this and this particular
entangled state of two black holes is
the ground state configuration of the
two black holes
that's the quantum mechanical
interpretation if you wish
um or in terms of gravity that you can
form
you can connect but you have this
connected wormhole
but but you create some negative energy
through some
fields that propagate in the space time
so spacetime becomes
topologically non-trivial what it means
is that it develops some kind of handle
so you have
the two black holes that are like little
holes in space and you should
picture them as connected by a kind of
hose that connects the two
black holes so you can have particles
that go inside the hose and then
come out in the space and then go in
again and
the propagation of these particles
creates some negative energy so in
quantum mechanics you can have negative
energy and that
stabilizes the whole setup and makes it
possible to have a traversal wormhole
now these traversal warfares
you build this way are consistent with
causality so what does that mean
that means that if you go through the
wormhole
you come out on the other side later
than you would
have come out if you had stayed outside
the wormhole
so they cannot be used for traveling
faster than light
so in the science fiction literature
it's common to find
wormholes where that are used to travel
faster than light or
travel to the to the past for example
and so on
but this this we think are
deeply uh inconsistent with the laws of
physics
so but this so there are different
things you can mean by the laws of
physics so
there are general principles of physics
that were established in the beginning
of the 20th century
like general relativity quantum
mechanics
quantum field theory so these are this
is a kind of framework
very framework general framework with
certain solid principles
so particular theories that we have
today
obey these principles but they kept
changing because
we needed to find more particles we
needed to add lots of particles since
the beginning of the 20th century
all the quarks all the we now probably
need to wear the
dark matter particle and so on um
but we whenever that was done it was
done within this framework
so we can ask what is possible within
this framework
so what is possible with ordinary this
is what i'm going to call ordinary
matter
by or non-exotic matter so
it doesn't doesn't mean the actual
matter we have in nature but this matter
database these kinds of principles that
we could in principle have perhaps but
we haven't detected yet for example
and this uh the idea is that with this
kind of matter you cannot produce
wormholes that allow you to travel
faster than light
and that's that's very good it's
actually an interesting theorem in uh
well that that this is not possible it
wasn't completely proven but several
aspects of it were proven
and it's an interesting interplay
between uh
positivity conditions of energy in
relativistic quantum field theory
and general relativity i mean at the
level of geometry you can imagine a
geometry that
connects points that are far away i mean
nobody forbids you from
writing down that geometry but einstein
theory is more than
just arbitrary geometries it's it's
geometries
that obey a certain equation it's called
the einstein equations
and the equation relates the shape of
the geometry to
uh the amount of energy or yeah the
amount of energy present in this
geometry
energy or matter or matter density etc
and these shapes that would allow you to
travel faster than light they require
a certain kind of negative energy which
is
not not possible in under those
circumstances
a certain small amount of negative
energy is allowed by quantum mechanics
and it's what
we exploited in these solutions that we
have discussed
and so so they allow you to construct
this these wormholes
it's interesting that you could have
these configurations which are
a topology different than the topology
of four dimensional flat space
um they seem difficult to
build so we only show that they are
solutions we don't know how
you could develop them into solutions
and one interesting aspect is that the
the
the first solution the first paper you
mentioned discusses these solutions
um in the context of uh it could even be
the standard model so it
could be the the matter that we know but
at very short distances
so distances that are so black holes
that are very very tiny
i mean those black holes would be
extremely difficult to produce
by artificial or maybe natural means
unless they were produced in the
variable universe
um and that's um one possibility so
and those differ from the the 2020 paper
differs in that it's um it's actually
displaying
a five or higher dimensional uh
background universe as opposed to the
2018 paper which was a four-dimensional
universe
can you comment on on why you it seems
it seems like we know we live in four
dimensions so why would we consider
higher dimensions why why can't we make
it work in four dimensional humanly
traversable wormhole in four dimensions
right
right so the the construction we had in
the 18 paper
relied on the existence of uh light
matter of
some light matter field so matter fields
which are let's say almost massless
and we don't have such well we have the
photon in nature but we
also wanted some charged matter fields
and we don't have those
uh we don't have massless ones we have
the electron that
is massive and um
so the idea was to postulate that maybe
we have some kind of dark sector
so the direct sector would be some
um type of matter that we only interact
with gravitationally but not
directly so in principle it might be
possible um
and postulating such that dark sector we
were asking whether it would be possible
to
a wormhole that is big enough that a
person could travel
it was mostly as a fun project so let's
just
see what's possible
and there is these models that involve
extra extra dimensions are kind of
equivalent to
a certain type of four-dimensional
matter theory of four-dimensional
very matter theory massless matter
and when it's very strong interacting it
could be
realized in terms of an extra dimension
and these models were discussed in the
past so people
thought oh maybe there are extra
dimensions
and so you could have
if the extra dimensions were flat like
flat space they could
have a size which is somewhat smaller
than a millimeter
um well now i think there is 50 microns
is the the current limit so it's
fairly smaller but anyway so that's the
current limit on the size of extra
dimensions if they were flat
but randall and syndrome realized so to
to researchers they they realized that
um you could have this extra dimension
could be
actually have infinite infinite size as
long as the space was curved
and so so you have the extra dimensional
space is curved
has negative curvature and then the
extra dimension is large
and it's the physics of this problem is
essentially equivalent to
adding massless matter to four
dimensional physics to four dimensions
if you don't like to think in terms of
five dimensions you can think in terms
of four dimensions
and in this setup um
you could by making the size of that
extra dimension large enough so for the
experimental limit current experimental
limit of 50 microns
you could have in principle traverse
over bourne
which is large enough for a person to go
through so let me
just maybe discuss how big it should be
for us to go through yeah
um now it's often said that
when we fall into a black hole we die at
the singularity because
the tidal forces or the forces of
gravity will kill us
but we could be falling into a black i
mean if we fall into stellar mass black
hole for example
so a black hole with the mass of the sun
which has size of order a few kilometers
so if we
fall into such a black hole we are still
bigger than the size of the black hole
but we'll be killed we will be killed
before we get even to the horizon
because we are very frail people
we we are very sensitive to tidal forces
and if
we are pushed from the head and the toes
in different directions we might die
so actually um you you need you need
some black hole to forward
the size of the earth so the horizon
should be of order the size of the earth
in order in order for us to fall and not
die at least at the horizon
and for similar reasons in this these
wormholes have to have a neck or
an opening so i mentioned the hose
before connecting the two points in
space-time
which has a size which is bigger than
the size of
of the order of the size of the earth
and
under those circumstances you could fall
in and
not be killed by the tidal forces
the tidal forces the forces similar to
the forces of tides that create the
tides
in the surface of the earth yeah on the
earth
um anyway so that so that requires
pretty big
black hole so that's a little
unfortunate that we are so frail
and this mechanism that releases the
wormholes is
also very
well it requires some quantum mechanical
effects so it's not too efficient so you
can make wormholes for their except they
will be separated the travel time will
be very long
so it will be further 10
10 000 years so that's the time it would
take you to go through the wormhole as
seen
by someone who remains outside the
wormhole now something quite fun about
this
is that if you for from the point of
view of the person that goes through the
wormhole that time is much shorter
that time is about it's less than a
second
um so
it's a bit like the twins paradox so in
the twins
ring paradox there is one of the twins
remains at rest and the other one
travels at very
high speeds and then returns then the
person
who travels at high speed and returns is
much younger than the
person who stayed at rest so this is
some something similar happens here the
person who goes through the wormhole
is much younger than the person who
sits outside the wormhole
and what do you attribute the kind of
fascination that people have
if the time travel aspects as you guys
show
are really not possible in the classic
sense in the interstellar
uh movie sense so to speak um what why
do you think people are so fascinated
and
why do you think that people use this as
a as a plot device so frequently
uh that it's almost become kind of a a
trope in a sense
uh that people really look look to
wormholes to solve a lot of problems in
in movie plot devices yeah well we
i mean the speed of light is
tough i mean it doesn't allow us to go
too far
that's right so it's not only a good
idea it's the law right yeah
it's the law and and it's
well i think authors like to
go outside the realm of
ordinarily established laws of physics
they
usually the the statement is oh well now
we that's what we think now maybe in the
future
we'll realize there is a way to go
around it
and that might well be true so it might
well be true that we find a way to run
but
going around this it's a very serious
change to the laws of physics so i
i i personally would bet very strongly
against
actually i remember a few years ago
there was an experiment claiming that
the neutrinos traveled faster
yeah the opera experiment that's right
yeah so i met one of my neighbors and
so you see you you know relativity is
wrong and so on
so okay fine i bet you a thousand
dollars that this experiment will go
away
he didn't want to take the bet
financially wise
uh and
yeah i mean it is possible everything is
possible but uh
there are some things that are more
unlikely than
than others yeah a lot of times we talk
on this channel and we have talked about
you know theories of everything which i
definitely want to get into
uh with you as well i can't miss the
opportunity to discuss it but
you know oftentimes this kind of uh
perception that
such things are not really falsifiable
or not testable
and so why should we kind of expend time
energy money
uh which is so finite in in value in in
in amount but infinite in value what are
kind of some of the motivations to study
these things when
you know for example some of the
criticism you know on the internet
of the of the recent humanly traversable
wormhole theory is that you know we
don't even know if the randall syndrome
cosmology model 5 or whatever even
exists and there's no evidence for that
so
why study you know kind of an edifice
that's built upon something which may
not even exist
right right right so here here we we are
exploring
not the the things that nature has
exists
but possible natures that are consistent
with the loss of the general principles
of physics of
general relativity especially relativity
etc quantum mechanics
with the goal of just understanding what
is possible the goal is not so
it's not so much to go and build and
look for this wormhole it's just
well that paper was just a fine exercise
but the main main goal is to i think the
main goal is to understand black holes
better quantum aspects of black holes
with the goal of understanding why well
how quantum gravity works so black holes
are
an interesting problem because they
force us to think about quantum graph
in interesting ways and if um
does that not presuppose that there
exists a
uh a theory of everything in other words
is that mandatory
uh certainly it seems that um wormholes
at least non-uh simply connected regions
are permissible
in classical gr but certainly to have
the wormhole as described
uh in the paper seems to rely on on
quantum processes as you
as you very rightfully explained but um
but i want to ask
maybe a deeper question which is uh kind
of about your opinion on theories of
everything in general
which is that you know do we need a
theory of everything
is it mandatory that we have i don't
like to match the
worth here of everything and i didn't
use it
but i i think what we need is a theory
of one what the we would call quantum
gravity so the quantum mechanics of
space-time
or ether of quantum space-time and this
is needed because the current theorists
do not explain what happens in certain
circumstances like
what happens at the very beginning of
the big bang or what happens in the
interior of black holes
and we would need that theory to really
put all these principles that we
discussed of the beginning of 20th
century together
and if you call that everything yeah
that's uh
yeah of everything that we learned in
the 20th century
general relativity and quantum physics
the the formalism of quantum field
theory came from
putting together quantum mechanics and
special relativity
and i think we like to put in general
relativity and
and this is a very
very constrained structure so the
question i mean one question that
i think that the fact that we need this
theory is clear uh
you could question whether we will ever
get this theory without doing
experiments
so i think this is a valid question now
why
why
do we think we might get there like this
is that
well we have some examples of candidate
theories that
are mostly like we should really think
of them as theories under construction
like string theory
and so on which uh which have
lots of mathematical intricacies and are
put together managed to put together
gravity and quantum mechanics
we don't know whether it's the right
theory for nature we don't know if
that's the correct framework to
correct theory special theory to
describe nature but
the goal i think is to is that by
thinking about those theories you
might even be able to abstract some
principles that
could be used to describe nature and
in the process people discuss discover
all kinds of relationships between these
theories and mathematics and other areas
of physics and
might even
and and we now think that gravity and
quantum mechanics are connected in many
different ways
and so perhaps a provocative idea is
that
you might be able to build a little toy
universe in a lab so
yeah yeah zia morali a friend of mine
has written a book about a big bang in a
little room which is a wonderful little
book
um i wanna uh before i turn to questions
from the audience i do just wanna follow
up and just i can't resist and if you'll
indulge me you know i mean
it's not so often i have a great
physicist to chat with uh
live and ask questions of a not personal
nature but i'd love to get your opinion
on why are there so many different
theories of everything i mean there's
wolfram has one our mutual friend eric
weinstein has had one
uh garrett lisi i mean they seem to
proliferate and these are
very very you know legitimate uh ideas
some of which are
are very creative stephen wolfram has a
completely uh different approach from
the
geometric uh approaches of people like
lisey and weinstein
what do you attribute first of all the
the upsurgence
and interest in new and theories of
everything
um well i guess
it's a natural frontier and uh people
have different ideas for how things
should go
some some ideas are more developed than
others
and and have had
i mean yeah like of course the final
arbiter of any idea is
uh to make a definite experimental
prediction that
you know could be falsified or
basically a prediction that you could go
and check
that this theory has there have been no
predictions like this for
from any of the theories um but
along the way some some theories have
had more uh
predict or let's say mathematical
predictions or predictions for others of
physics or
some interesting more interesting
structure
and some are consistent with these
principles of the 20th century physics
that i discussed and some are not so um
for example it's not clear whether
waltram's
ideas are consistent with the principles
of relativity and causality and so on
uh time doesn't it's not
and uh yeah so
um yeah i think uh the
for those of us that uh work on uh
string
inspired ideas the what we like is that
it's a theory with
well-defined rules and well at least in
some regimes
where you can do calculations and it's
compatible with these general principles
of
transition century physics and when we
look at
some of the questions are coming up
about connections between quantum
field theory one of my listeners whose
name is
rust in peace who is a frequent
contributor on the channel he's asking
uh whether or not the black hole
information paradox shows that quantum
field theory is incomplete
in other words do we need a
fundamentally new theory uh
to merge quantum mechanics and gr as
illustrated by the black hole paradox
yes i think i think i think that's right
but it's incomplete when when gravity is
dynamical so when the effects of
uh when the effects of the finiteness of
the newton constant is
is important and then
others are asking about you know the
perceived i get this a lot you know
failure of string theory to you know
come up with this but i think
i think you've already sort of addressed
this that uh it may be
sort of too much to ask for or maybe not
phrasing
the meaning of the word theory of
everything and maybe there's too much
expectation of
things like string theory so what's your
current appraisal of the
of the state of affairs and string
theory for example
um well i think uh string theory i view
it
mainly as a candidate theory for quantum
gravity and
it's a theory that's been fairly
developed and has a
very interesting mathematical structure
and has led to
interesting connections between quantum
field theory and gravity or between
different quantum field theories
and quantum filtering condensed matter
and
quantum mechanics and thinking about
yeah quantum mechanics and space time in
general
and if um
but yeah the fact that there isn't a
concrete experimental prediction is a
problem
and uh i think uh
we we understood that the landscape of
possible there was a road map for
experimental predictions in the late 80s
which was well we'll we'll have we have
this very nice 10 dimensional theory and
we'll find the internal space on which
it's compactified so six dimensions are
small we'll find
the possible shapes there will be a
finite small number of possible shapes
we'll we'll find which is the one that
gives the standard model and
we'll be able to calculate things that
was the roadmap
that roadmap turned out to be uh
well it was more complicated than
expected because there were many many
possible shapes and many
then the number was so big that it's
very difficult to study them them all or
study them in a way that you could
really make a concrete prediction um
and the the current thinking is that the
the just into to explain or accommodate
the cosmological constant
you need to uh to exploit this
complexity
and and so
so the typical like the typical so if
you take an off-the-shelf
internal space you will get the
cosmetical content which is too large
so the idea that the current idea well
among all the ones there are so many
that one will have the right
cosmological constant but that also
makes it
very difficult to make a concrete
british prediction
but i mean people are some people are
are still
well there definitely many people are
trying to make statistical predictions
so maybe you
don't know exactly which of the vacuum
where we live in or which
but making perhaps statistical
predictions of what that landscape
is sometimes called the string landscape
of what that landscape looks like
i personally think that also this
connection between gravity and and
quantum mechanics maybe can lead to a
different kind of prediction
a different kind of uh connection
between
the id these ideas and and the rest of
physics
and concrete physics which is via
perhaps quantum computers and maybe
quantum experiments in the lab of
building something
some systems some complex ideas that
very complex systems
uh behave uh in a way that can be
described by
a certain space time it's not our four
dimensional space time but
maybe some auxiliary two dimensional
space time and so on
and there are people thinking more
actively about
how to get these ideas to work
um and so this is again something that
people you know do in string theory do
but uh
it's a different angle on the connection
and kind of an allied effect to that is
uh located uh behind my upper uh
right shoulder over here i'm pointing to
a couple of cmb
balls i want to uh bring up an allied
question which is uh related to the
multiverse and you mentioned
the landscape i want to talk a little
bit about that
in our remaining 15 20 minutes that we
have
so i want to read something to you from
a while back in quantum magazine
which uh which talked about the study of
non-gaussianities
and in quantum magazine they say uh the
study of rigorous study of
non-gaussianities took off in 2002
when wal maldasena a revered
monk-like theorist at the institute for
advanced study
calculated what's known as a
gravitational floor the minimum number
of triangles and other shapes that are
guaranteed to exist in the sky
due to the unavoidable effect of gravity
during cosmic inflation
cosmologists had been struggling to
calculate the gravitational floor for
more than a decade
since it would provide a concrete goal
for experimentalists
if the floor is reached and still no
triangles are detected maldisana
explained
then inflation is wrong so uh i want to
ask
you because i don't i actually
interviewed a real monk last week and
i have to say you guys have some
somewhat similar you know countenances
you're very
uh very revered and very reserved uh but
uh i don't know if the monk-like
attribute is is accurate but but leaving
that aside
um uh behind me are these balls i'm
going to go get one while you're on the
screen but can you first talk a little
bit about what is a non-gaussianity
in the cosmological context and i'll
bring up some visuals for the audience
while uh you indulge me
yeah so the
an interesting fact about the universe
is that it's very close to uniform
on long distances but another
in fact this is not perfectly uniform
there were some
primordial inhomogeneity so it was to
first approximation homogeneous but with
tiny little
e-homogeneities that i guess you've been
studying for
your career and that's a map of the
those in homogeneities as we
see them through the cmb um
this in homogeneities it's believed that
they were produced through quantum
effects they were due to quantum
fluctuations during the beginning of
inflation
and so they are random so the phantom
fluctuations are random
but in quantum theory the um
the randomness has some pattern so
so there are different patterns of
randomness and so the simplest pattern
is so called gaussian pattern
where each each region could sort of
fluctuate independently of the others
roughly speaking
it's not exactly the same but um each
let's say wave fluctuates differently
from the others and that's like the
simplest pattern
the bell curve the gaussian distribution
um but in
in actual theories uh actual theories
are interacting and
the fluctuation in one place creates
some
decreases or increases another type of
fluctuation in a similar region
so um so you have some known gaussian
effects so
some language means that there were some
interactions between the waves
you could view this as waves or
fluctuations in the geometry of the
shape of the universe
and we
this uh these deviations from gaussian i
think
gives us very deep information about the
interactions that were present during
the inflationary times
during the times of inflation when these
fluctuations were produced
and so the simplest interaction that we
had was interaction of gravity
so that if you have a fluctuation that
created created an over density
okay created some gravitational
potential and then some other
fluctuation would
look different and that's uh this
so-called gravitational flow so it's the
minimum amount of known
deviations from the gaussianity that you
would need if inflation is correct
at least or at least single field
inflation um
but in principle there could be larger
effects due to
other particles that could could have
existed during that time
and in some some ways the early
inflation is like a particle detector or
a particle collider that
you you you create all these particles
that could be created so the universe at
the time
was expanding rapidly and there's an
effect similar to the effect
of hawking radiation that we discussed
before that creates this
quantum effect that creates this these
waves these longer this
fluctuations and it can also create
other particles
which have mass proportional to the
effective temperature
of these equations and
they um so if you created those
particles it could also imprint all
kinds of interesting patterns
uh in the sky i mean so far so far no
non gaussianities were detected so
that is uh it's very very close to
gaussian
but still there are a couple of orders
of magnitude to go
to to get to this floor somehow to this
minimal amount
and i guess there are very interesting
experiments going on trying to
calculate this to measure i mean to
experimentally measure this
non-gaussian it is better yeah that's
right and
certainly a hot topic not only the uh
the actual pursuit of non-gassianities
which is there are very few
ways we can actually access this
enormous particle accelerator as you
call it which is a nice way to think
about the
extremely early universe but one of them
is potentially through
a cosmic microwave backgrounds
polarization and in
doing so we make the hypothesis that if
inflation took place there will be this
stochastic background
of primordial gravitational waves not
the late time gravitational waves
detected recently fairly recently on
cosmic time scales by lee
by ligo but actually we could detect a
a background suffusing the early
universe
unfortunately these are kind of like
no-go theorems in some sense
and what appeals to me and i should take
a step back what i liked about the
non-gaussianity
effect is that it gives another it gives
a prediction
that's a lower limit so i'm kind of sick
of upper limits we've had
so many upper limits in physics for so
long that it's nice sometimes to get
a lower limit so let me explain to my
audience who might not be familiar
an upper limit says that a signal can be
no larger than a certain amount
so it says that the higgs boson could be
no larger than you know
three you know 300 or or whatever gev
in mass uh but a lower limit allows you
to say that
such a quantity exists and it's bigger
than a certain value and in fact that
value can be bigger than zero so for
example we know that neutrinos have mass
we have an upper limit on the mass of
neutrinos from neutrino oscillation
experiments
we also uh know that there's a lower
limit on the
on the mass of the neutrino sorry we
know the l or limit exists from
from neutrino oscillations we know the
upper limit exists from from
collider experiments from direct
detection experiments and from cosmology
and so we're kind of coming at the
target from both ends it's not enough to
say i'm lower than
you know 600 meters tall and i'm bigger
than
one micron tall what you'd like to have
is a very tight range between the upper
and lower limits
but when you have a lower limit it gives
a target for an experimentalist like me
i always say i'm just a simple
experimental astrophysicist you got to
break it down
into and there are very few things like
that we know that uh we don't know that
gravitational waves exist
um and the primordial sense we know that
they exist in the late universe
but uh but your your uh work on
non-gaussianities really provides sort
of a no-go theorem
which could be used in in combination
with the primordial b-mode search but
there's a problem
in that i think that we've we've
basically hit a point of diminishing
returns
when you wrote that paper in the early
2000s that was pre
uh wmap and now we have not only the
beautiful phenomenal
cha world you know changing results of
wmap but also planck
and it's very hard to do much better in
the cmd's temperature
so i wonder you know how much better can
we do to you know in the
in your opinion before we hit this floor
which is known as cosmic variants
uh beyond which we can't really improve
in other words
might your lower limit also be an upper
limit in the sense that we'll never be
able to detect it
because of fundamental intrinsic
variances
in the in the pattern of fluctuations in
the microarray background
well that's i think a subject you
probably know better than me
um and uh i'm i'm
told by the experts that with the
current angular resolution
that you could get the cmb with and so
on
uh you just don't have enough uh power
to get to this floor
yeah i think we're getting very close i
mean yeah diminishing returns in terms
of noise level and angular resolution
uh but there may be other triangles in
in terms of
large-scale structure is that a
possibility to look for
non-gaussianities
yeah so large-scale structure is
something that would allow you to go a
little further
because you see basically one
difference is that the the cmb map is
two dimensional another
skill structure it could be a
three-dimensional map
and there's been also some more
futuristic
ideas like looking at the so-called 21
centimeter
hydrogen emission lines to to see
uh the matter distribution also in the
early universe and to again make a map
which is three-dimensional and uh i mean
that
that might be the best hope but well
people yeah
this is further into the future we don't
know that
21 centimeters primordial signal is
really there
i want to ask you a question that's
maybe a meta question
when you make a prediction about this
how difficult
is it to separate your own natural
curiosity
and feeling of ownership over this
theory i mean i think we could both
agree
it'll be very challenging to detect a
humanly traversable wormhole
but when you make predictions such as
these no-go theorems for inflation
or the many other contributions you've
made to physics
how much how tempting is it as a
theorist
to really advocate you know for the
pursuit of your particular theoretical
models and
and and see confirmation in them
wherever they are yeah
yeah i think i think there are theories
that the
proposed models uh like there are more
phenomenologies that produce models
i wouldn't call this humanly traversable
model as a particular theory that i want
to see confirmed in experiment because i
think it's very unlikely that the
universe is described by the randall
syndrome 2 model and so on
um i view must a little more as a
theoretical fan exercise a bit of
science fiction
i told lisa randall that i was going to
write the science fiction paper
i think he should maybe another side of
the monk
known as malta cena
and um yeah i i i tend to work on things
which are not predicting specific models
but trying to find general principles
and
uh yeah general ideas exploring
this more general features um
but yeah i
for example with with nema we discussed
the possibility of seeing extra
particles during inflation and so on
through this cosmological collider would
be really fine if that was seen i mean
but there would be but well
i again i i don't think it's necessarily
likely we didn't
we didn't think that it was the most
likely scenario right
so i think part of the theory's
work is to figure out where interesting
signals could lie
or where it should look for interesting
signals they might not
be necessarily the most likely signals
but if they were present
they would tell you a lot so you should
make sure there are certain signals you
should make sure not to
miss a list and
yeah that's uh part of what i'm doing
but some
some people are more more practically
oriented and want to see what
actually the data is saying and the this
is
yeah what can be extracted from actual
data that you for example
are taking right and to what extent you
know if you were
kind of a director of experimental
research
how would you choose to prioritize just
on a selfish level
your many enthusiasms that you have
how would you you know rate the
likelihood of
the existence of these randall syndrome
i mean you obviously say that there's
not not terribly likely and they're
almost in the realm of science fiction
as are wormholes but inflation is
held in the multiverse the string
landscape swampland these are all
held by you know there's an awful lot of
energy devoted at most universities to
this pursuit so how do you
how would you or if you were the
director of all research and physics on
planet earth
uh from your monastery how would you how
would you allocate this
very precious limited amount of time or
really
attention
um well you have to decide where
well i think this run this
this this randall syndrome well the
particular version that
we considered i think it's highly
unlikely
and in general the randolph idea is an
interesting idea
not this particular model but the one
that was trying to explain the hierarchy
mode
and should be explained should should be
explored
has the nice feature that is simple
relatively simple to explore relative to
other
particle physics scenarios and it's a
it's slightly different scenario than
the ones
typically people consider like new
particles structure which is basically
similar to the one we already had
and so it's worth looking for it
produces weird signals so it's
interesting
to look at and people looked at it and
mainly in the run-up to the lhc as
possible
things that the lhc could see now the
lhc didn't see any of them but
it was important that he looked for all
this
all the possible things so it was an era
before the experiment where
i think it was important to look for
exotic scenarios
look for you know possibilities like
super symmetry
look for various possibilities and well
then you experiment and
you make sure you don't miss any any
possible signal
so i think something that is important
is
some diversity in in approaches and
various ideas so i think if you
ask me what science policy should be you
should find different uh
various ideas just in theory various
different ideas
you said just in theory or do you mean
in theory this is a very important
principle in experiment it's a little
more tricky because
sometimes you need a critical mass of
people following
a definite you know definite experiment
and
you know there are many many people
studying cosmic microwave
physics and i think it's a very
interesting
very interesting topic and i i feel yeah
so now one of the frontiers is the study
of the primordial fluctuations i find
this the
most interesting aspects of cnbc i mean
cmp physics has many more aspects
you know very well like measuring
neutrino masses i don't know how much
that you mentioned and i don't know the
physics of early clusters etc
and but yeah this this
this discovery of primordial
fluctuations is
very interesting for what it says about
the universe the consequences it has for
us i mean
we are here thanks to these primordial
fluctuations in a way and
um so i think it's a conceptually
very interesting area i mean very
interesting result that
people should know and i don't know it's
fun for the public to know
again you could say well this doesn't
give any technological application and
so on but i think it's a fundamental
scientific thing that is interesting for
for us to know
it has a very important cultural value
and speaking of cultural value there's
other ideas and you know there's an
approach to let
a thousand theories bloom so to speak so
i'm getting
questions about your impressions of
alternates to
inflation obviously you've spent a lot
of time thinking about inflation
but what if inflation didn't happen what
if
the models of your nearby neighbor over
across the way and jadwin hall paul
steinhardt
is a friend of the show uh the sort of
cyclic bouncing models or roger penrose
who's been
also been on the show discussing
conformal cyclic cosmology what are your
thoughts uh
on those on those models alternatives to
an inflationary story
um well i i should say that i think it's
it's interesting to try to find
alternatives to try to find alternatives
to inflation
um and i we were discussing with some
students and
some alternatives and but i have to say
that
none of the alternatives reach the level
of precision and rigor
just even theoretical rigor uh
that inflation has so inflation is an
idea where
you take the simplest idea uh
starovinsky model
and you can do the calculation of
fluctuations in that model
was done and um
and you get some prediction and
you know the prediction doesn't change
so it's not that the new theories come
and they change the prediction and it
depends on exactly how you do the
calculation
there is a well defined way to do the
calculation and that's it in these other
models it's unclear what the roots are
for doing the calculations so the models
have
um an uncalculable element so some level
of assumption
in in the model itself so you say well
you start with some well-defined process
there is a point where
an unknown physics happens where you
need a quantum theory of gravity is some
theory we don't completely have
and then you make some assumption and
then you get some prediction
but the prediction changes with the
assumption and maybe the assumption
changed and
well i mean it it doesn't mean that
those
models are all wrong i mean maybe there
could be an idea the conceptual idea
might be
correct but they certainly not calculate
doesn't have the level of calculation
even already internally the calculation
of the rigor that inflation has so
as a theory uh they are behind in that
sense
um and while yeah comparing to
experiment well
many of these smalls were designed to
agree with experiment
at least experiments so far but yeah
they some of them make different
predictions so
you can right yeah i guess the question
is attention you know there's such a
dominance in most departments have
you know uh cosmologists where they're
working on inflation if they have
you know early universe cosmology uh we
have multiple people here at san diego
we're very fortunate my colleagues
rafael flauger dan green
and others but but thinking about
alternatives and how difficult it is to
get traction
imagine you do come up with some theory
and you are working
more or less i mean my the way i always
put it is people like eric weinstein or
people like roger penrose cannot get
traction
you know and not have graduate students
and sort of people working on it
how how easy is it or or how how does
the
kind of monopoly effect does it does it
take place where
a theory is so dominant it's so
attractive that it basically sucks
out the oxygen from alternatives that
may prove
superior had they had the intellectual
capital behind them um
well i mean
it is a problem if everyone does the
same thing
but i think there is an incentive for
people to
come up with another theory that is a
competitor um
but that this it has to be a serious
competitor in the sense that
uh at least it has to be internally
internally
somewhat at least calculable or
and there are there are people working
on some alternatives it's not i mean
there was a paper today
about some other alternative theory so
um
i i think it's well i think people
there are people proposing alternative
scenarios but
if the alternative scenario is very
vague it doesn't get traction because
you
yeah you don't know what what's the next
step or what
i mean it's good to have it in mind and
my
my feeling is that perhaps uh
someone working in some problems in you
know quantum gravity or gravity in
general might have an idea for a
slightly
for a different scenario perhaps and
then
that would be reasonable and would lead
to
either different yeah well at least he
has to agree with the predictions have
been
checked but uh experimentally i mean uh
the scaling bar the nearly scale
environment spectrum of fluctuations and
so on
um but um yeah could
lead to other predictions i think it's
interesting to
come up with different things i mean
historically for example
people france and dk came up with this
alternative theory of gravity
where there is also scalar force and so
on and that play the
i mean that's the advantage of being a
theoretically well-defined theory and
then you could
use it to compare you know experiments
against uh
you take gr and this other theory
general relativity and this other theory
and you could compare them
and see what would you get so
i feel yeah
yeah i want to then turn towards a
completely different direction which is
your paper
uh entitled the symmetry and simplicity
of the laws of physics and the higgs
boson where
you use uh theories of economics as an
as an analog
to help people understand an approach to
how the how this very complex notion
so-called higgs mechanism could be
understood in terms of a monetary or
economic analogy
and that was building on as you cite you
know the work of my friends pia malali
and eric weinstein in the um
sort of what they consider and and
they've talked to me
about this sort of an upgrade of
differential calculus
and i want to ask you are there other
applications of gauge through i mean if
you ask people
they might have heard of calculus uh not
the kind on on my teeth or something but
they might have heard of calculus they
might know what a derivative is or an
integral
but almost none of them know what a
gauge you know theory is so first of all
um what is a gauge theory
why is it useful to physicists and are
there
other analogs that could be used to
either understand gage
theory as you use economics based on you
know pia and eric's work
but also uh to extend this to other
fields where
you know people like me might not see
the connection between gage theory and
some other analog and physical world
um yeah so gauge theory
is basically a theory where you
introduce some redundancies
that help you understand the
that help you describe the theory but
that they are not do not reflect the
physics or they're not real so you
insert you you produce something which
is kind of conventional and
you but at the end of the day it's not
the
doesn't reflect reality um an
example is well the gauge potential of
electromagnetism
so that both the the
electric potential or magnetic
potentials that we discussed for
electromagnetism
they are not they're not physical you
can shift them by constant you can shift
them by some
certain particular functions and what's
really physical are the electric and
magnetic fields
and electromagnetism is a gauge gauge
theory in this sense
and many of the theories of particle
physics are also gauge theory so it's a
very important type of theory
that we we use to describe physics um
and um yeah so the
this economic analysis is based on uh
thinking about um is an analogy between
economics and electromagnetism
and uh it uh
well should i describe it or yeah so no
please
yeah so the basic idea is to think about
the
currency so people
sometimes well so for example dollars
right we measure things in dollars
but if someone decided to change the
value of the dollar say let's say
people tomorrow they decide that uh well
the hundred dollars of today will be
valid uh
one new dollar of tomorrow let's say
we could invent a different name let's
say one
change the number of zeros and define a
new unit of currency but
if all the salaries adjust appropriately
and all the exchange rates with other
currencies in the world that just
appropriately
that change doesn't affect anybody and
doesn't
uh it's just a change in the units we
use to measure
what the value of things and i come from
a country in argentina where this
happened many times so many times they
took
a few zeros out of the currency through
this type of process
now that's an example of a gauge
symmetry that's a
something that doesn't change how rich
you are because you change the number of
zeros you have in the currency
now there there is some other more
physical information in the
uh more real information in the exchange
rates between different countries
so but not exactly exchange rates
between two countries because if you
have the exchange rate only between two
countries
uh if any one of them changes the
currency that the particular nominal
value of exchange rate will also change
so when you change the currency units
but
if you have the exchange rates between
three different countries
and imagine them arranging the vertex of
a triangle
and so you have the exchange rate
between any of the
two countries along the edges of the
triangle
then each individual's exchange rate
depends on the
on the currency units of each one but
imagine you travel between
the three countries in a in a circle the
net
gain that you get by exchanging those
exchange rates um
that's uh independent of the currency
units so if you gain a factor of two or
a factor of 1.1 when you go around in
one way or you lose a factor
you know you get a factor 0.09 i mean
0.09
um that is really physical and
that's what in physics we call a
magnetic field so
um it's analogous to magnetic field
now if you have a situation like this
where you can make money by going around
these
three countries then you would have
speculators that
buy one currency sell it and so on and
now normally this wouldn't happen if we
were in equilibrium or
but you would think that the exchange
rates would adjust themselves so that
this doesn't happen
but imagine for a second that the
exchange rates are arbitrary
and you could make money by doing this
then you would have speculators that go
around this
these three countries now this is what
happens in
nature when you have a an electron so an
electron goes around the
magnetic field so you have a magnetic
field electron goes around in a circle
and so the electron is a bit like those
speculators that are trying to make
money
um and
yeah so that's an example and and
yeah so you can have fun some fun with
this example and you can
assume some behavior for the people who
set the exchange rates and the
speculators and so on and get the
maxwell equations etc
um i mean this is not too surprising
given that maxwell himself
got the maxwell equations from a
mechanical model and we think
we don't have that particular mechanical
model that maxwell had but there are
many microscopic models that
give rise to maxwell's equations this is
just one of them
um now the
but in in actual economics the um
we're in sort of like a higgs phase of
electromagnetism it's analogous to a
a situation where the electromagnetism
spontaneously broken
and because the prices of ordinary goods
that we can take between one country and
the next
is analogous to the higgs the higgs
field
so like we could have a certain quant
certain thing like gold or oil or
you know bananas that we can take
between different countries
and uh so the speculators could also
commerce in this
uh quantities and
the prices of these quantities are
[Music]
well are certainly arbitrary they depend
on the monetary units
but we could we could set our monetary
units in terms of those prices so we can
some all the countries could say well we
measure everything in terms of the price
of bananas
anyway and that's uh
then the exchange rates between
different countries would become more
meaningful
and yeah so well that's that's roughly
the the analogy i
could go on on it and then are there
other
you know kind of approaches that where
gage theory might not be
widely appreciated as a you know
potential
uh potential under you know way to
understand
to understand something well yeah i
don't
i don't know so you are asking me to
find the other analysis
where i don't know of another one that
is as close as
uh economic one um
yeah and then of course with the higgs
you make your electro weak force you you
talk about you know
spheres replacing circles i think that's
delightful
and uh an interesting extension of the
work um
that we discussed i want to talk just in
the final few minutes if you if you
still have a little bit more time we'll
finish up soon
a couple more questions from people uh
in the
in the chat room how how how is it
possible that
by adding uh these dimensions it seems a
little reminiscent of you know coluzza
cline
etc so what's the difference between a
physical dimension which we have no
evidence of existing and
sort of a mathematical dimension where
we can add things that will even though
they may not exist in
in in reality
um well a physical dimension is
some dimension where some physics can
happen
so uh you know a particle can move in
the extra dimensions gravity can extend
to the extra dimensions and so on
so that's what we normally call a
physical dimension
i'm not sure what the mathematical
dimension is i mean
of course the concept of many dimensions
in math
makes sense and it could be applied to
depends on what your mathematical
application is so
for example people who think about
you know recognizing language artificial
intelligence for language
think of words as vectors in a higher
dimensional space and stuff like this so
this is some other application of the
idea of the dimension that has nothing
to do
right and gauge just you know being
analogous vocabulary
lookup table between different cultures
or languages yeah
interesting um a few more questions uh
from from both me and my audience
uh so one involves uh you're at this
very a little bit less technical now if
you'll indulge so
uh you're at the one of the most storied
institutions uh in the
annals of all of science the institute
for advanced study
uh what is sort of your daily life like
there is it
all you know contemplation or what's a
day in the life of
besides your six hours of prayer fasting
every day as a monk
what what's a day look like for you uh
dr maldasena
well i think my day is similar to the
days in
university researchers we
normally we go come to our offices we
look we look at the papers that came out
the previous night
we we discussed with our colleagues we
maybe are working on some papers we do
calculations
as a theorist we spend a lot of time
discussing calculations and math
and you know different approaches to
actually doing certain calculations
uh there is of course maybe some
discussion of more
conceptual things but that's what we
mostly
spend our days on there we go to talks
presentations
like and then
uh in terms of um you know kind of
future things that you're interested in
uh what's sort of the near term looking
like for you
in terms of research directions maybe
students and uh advisories
yeah so i currently we're
we're all work we're all mainly working
on my group
working on aspects of black holes
quantum aspects of black holes trying to
understand
what the black hole interior is
understanding better the information
paradox
and there was
recently very interesting progress on
understanding how the information
comes out in hawking radiation
papers by bennington
by various research groups and
and yeah so that's a very exciting
development in the last couple of years
and so i've been working mostly on that
so the last question that i have let me
just scan the chat section here we've
got a hundred plus people in the chat
section
a lot of these have been have an ass so
i think we've
covered most of the questions from the
audience i'm going to finish up with two
questions for you that i ask
in some version or another i ask uh most
if not all of my guests
and that first question kind of relates
to
uh the the far future of
of humanity you know hopefully you live
to be
you know many well first of all i want
to ask you actually i don't i don't get
this opportunity very often
if i could give you one of my kids is
working on a pill
which he calls the never dying pill
which would allow the
uh the the injester whoever eats it
to live forever but no one else on the
entire planet would live forever i want
to ask you
one would you take such a pill to live
forever as you are right now with
everything you know
can't take anyone with you not even me
yeah i don't know maybe yes yeah
probably yes
okay and the next question revolves
around something that
in hebrew is known as an ethical will so
alfred nobel
left the famous will which endowed a
prize that bears his name
but the will in addition to recognizing
uh
discoveries and inventions in physics
chemistry etc
was meant also to benefit all mankind so
have some benefit
towards the human species and so in that
way it was what was known as an ethical
will it had
more than just a monetary financial
tangible
purpose and and and outcome of it i want
to ask you
if you were to write an ethical will
what kind of wisdom
or or things knowledge that you've
obtained in your life
would you want to pass on separate
completely from your
your financial material will
well the importance of collaboration of
truth seeking in general
think these are
important principles and do you see
yourself primarily as an educator
as a researcher as a mentor a student
how do you
how do you think of yourself and what is
your sort of superpowers that allow you
to be so successful
well i think of myself as a researcher
first and
yeah also mentor i have the
well one of the secrets is that we have
outstanding young people coming through
the institute that
become our collaborators and so on and
uh yeah that's uh
that's perhaps one of the greatest
privileges of being here
yeah absolutely uh then i want to ask
you um
because i don't get to ask people uh of
your stature
and prominence so often uh what's your
theory
or what's your um if you had to predict
what's more likely uh so to speak that
the multiverse exists
uh or that god exists
um i think that god exists
is more likely very good care to
elaborate are you are you do you
practice any religion out of curiosity
yeah yeah i am sort of catholic but um
yeah
i think some general idea of god i like
the idea of
superior intelligence and so on um
but yeah um well i think the multiverse
is
is likely the multiverse i think it's
yeah it's also likely
maybe both are maybe bothered it's
difficult to see how to
prove it yeah it's also difficult to see
how to prove the existence of god
yeah i asked freeman dyson that same
question more or less
uh when i was writing my book and he
said well both are kind of
great puzzles um you know puzzles can be
solved or maybe mysteries he said is
is the right word because a mystery
might not be solvable
a puzzle could be solved i might not be
able to solve a rubik's cube
although i was joking today i solved
five sides of a rubik's cube but i'm
having trouble with that sixth side
uh but but in reality i was wondering uh
the last question kind of maybe relates
to that as well
or actually the second to last question
if you have a few more seconds
um the second last question is life on
other planets and intelligent life in
particular
do you think that's a worthy you know
quest given finite resources
what do you think the likelihood is of
extraterrestrial intelligence that we
could
communicate with potentially
um well i think this is this is also one
of the great questions that i think
we should devote some resources to
answering um
and uh yeah i think
the likelihood it's uh well it's hard to
tell
of course the fermi paradox i guess you
all know
um and yeah so that
that makes me think it's unlikely but uh
yeah i'm very interesting okay the last
question
is the anthropic principle then it's
very unlikely
right that's right and fine-tuning
exactly
yeah uh so the last question uh that i
have
uh is usually i don't know if you've
ever seen the movie 2001 a space odyssey
yeah but there are these monoliths that
play a role in the
in the movie as a plot device these are
left by an ancient civilization
uh to be found when humanity is ready
technologically to appreciate them and
i want to ask you if richard feynman
once said the following he said if
if there was a cataclysm that destroyed
all scientific knowledge
and you could only pass on one sentence
to the next generation of creatures
what statement would contain the most
information in the fewest words now i'm
not going to ask you for one sentence
he said the simplest uh one was about
atoms and how
the everything is made up of atoms but
now we know so much more than what he
knew in the 60s or 70s when he's made
that statement i want to ask you what
would you put on a monolith
a time capsule that would represent the
culmination of physics knowledge or
personal knowledge
that would last for a billion years as a
time capsule for the future
[Music]
yeah i think this this idea that
matter is made out of particles is very
important
yeah probably that perhaps general
relativity
depends on how much you can put in but
right yeah the sentence
could be a runner it's made out of small
particles that's something that fits in
a sentence but
very good uh well uh doctor juan
maldonado it's been a pleasure to talk
to you i hope to
uh maybe contact you again in the future
as i develop a little more understanding
of your
uh excellent papers very provocative
very entertaining papers
as as is your style and i appreciate
this very much i'll put some resources
in the show note links to your papers
links to a talk you gave at the
institute
uh several years back on the same topic
uh i want to
express my gratitude to you one for
sharing so much of your time with my
audience today
sure it's a pleasure yeah thanks thank
you one be be well i'll talk to you
again soon thank you very much